doors unlock
welcome to your 2022 weekly ticket
well the start of 2022 seems to be all
about tom holland spider-man no way home
only needed one weekend to become the
highest grossing movie of 2021 and it's
already swung into the top 10 highest
grossing films of all time in domestic
earnings february sees holland taking on
a new franchise uncharted and adaptation
of the treasure-hunting adventure video
game uncharted has a younger version of
nathan drake than the video games
pitting holland opposite mark wahlberg's
seasoned fortune hunter sully speaking
with total film holland reveals that his
youthful casting came about because he
pitched sony on a young james bond i had
a meeting after ordering spider-man far
from home with sony to pitch this idea
of a young bond film that i'd come up
with it was the origin story of james
bond it didn't really make sense it
didn't work it was the dream of a young
kid and i don't think the bond estate
were particularly interested the idea of
a young bond film sparked this idea in
turn that you could do a nathan drake
story as an origin story rather than as
an addition to the games and that opened
a conversation young nathan drake swings
into theaters this february still no
word yet on that next double 07 though
sticking with actor movie pitches chris
evans will play gene kelly in a film
based on his own story idea the untitled
film will follow a boy who works on the
mgm lot in 1952 and creates an imaginary
friendship with the singing and the
rainstar evans knives out director ryan
johnson will produce making good on this
promise yeah listen hey ryan will you
hire me again are you kidding me let's
do a musical hey don't tempt me
kelvin harrison jr is re-teaming with
loose director julius onna for a biopic
on one of the most influential artists
of the 20th century jean-michel basquiat
basquiat exploded in the 1980s new york
city art world at the age of 22 where he
was the youngest artist to exhibit at
the whitney biennial in new york jeffrey
wright starred as basquiat in a 1990s
film made by painter julian schnabel but
this portrait of the artist titled samo
lives will be the first film about
basquiat made by a fellow black artist
oh it's tough do you like scary movies
well the slasher that broke all the
horror movie rules is back for a recall
the fifth installment of scream brings
the heart of the original cast nev
campbell courtney cox and david arquette
back to woodsboro they're matched by a
fresh new cast of plucky teen residents
led by melissa barrera jenna ortega
dylan minnette and jack quaid 25 years
after the original series of murders in
woodsboro a new killer emerges in the
ghost face mask and sydney prescott must
return to uncover the truth we recently
had the scream legacy actors campbell
cox and arquette sit down and ask each
other questions about the iconic
franchise what excites you most about a
new generation of horror fans seeing a
new scream or any scream for the first
time
what's so exciting about it is the
screen is new it's it's
it's a revitalized scream it is scary
it's gorier
and i think that people will want to
know what happened in the first screen
to see with these characters and how
they all tied together and so then i
think we get to start all over again i'd
love that
12 year olds you're gonna know who yep
these characters are anyway
what character from any movie or show
you've played would most likely survive
the scream film
the guy from john's i'm gonna say for
you
i'm not sure who i really would be susie
toler from wild things
i think um
monica keller
i'd probably say gordy boggs the
wrestler from ready to roll there you go
okay which scream character from the
past four movies do you wish had
survived to join you in the sequels
randy yeah randy randy was loved and and
funny and yeah he was but i gotta go
with my sister rose
what line from scream is quoted back to
you uh by fans the most oh sydney hello
sydney
that was a scary movie i'm dewey not
toofy
get it all the time
thank you and thank you again for the
new scream the production recreated the
killer's house from the first film how
did you react to seeing that on set um
a lot of memories flooded back was
really emotional and it was done such a
great job and there was one of the
characters his name wes so there was a
post of a big sign i was like ah he's
right here and
he's not and so it was it was emotional
yeah totally as a scream uh scream
veterans what advice did you have for
the new cast
nothing
so professional i was like they knew
what they were
a little more professional than me
everyone's more professional
you know
i swear it almost no i know but i
know you're right
they probably are more sandy at this
point
new in theaters this week is scream and
bell you may not be able to start over
in the real world
but you can start over
in the world of you bell is the newest
film from beloved animator momodu hosura
it centers on suzu a shy high school
student living in a rural village in
japan for years she's kept to herself
but when she enters a massive virtual
world called you she becomes belle her
online persona a gorgeous and globally
cherished singer one day her performance
is interrupted by a monstrous creature
after it's chased away by her fans susan
embarks on a quest to uncover the
identity of this mysterious
quote-unquote beast and to discover her
true self and available to watch at home
today is sing two and a journal for
jordan this is the entertainment capital
of the world
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running in sing two buster
moon and his friends have played sold
out show after sold out show in his
local theater buster decides it's time
to try the big city and must persuade
reclusive rock star clay callaway to
join them for the opening of a new show
the problem is callaway hasn't performed
in 15 years and the band has not met him
yet matthew mcconaughey rhys witherspoon
scarlett johansson taryn edgerton tori
kelly and nick kroll returned to voice
their beloved characters in the sequel
to the 2016 film and the added star
voices for the sequel include halsey
pharrell williams eric andre and u2's
bono as clay callaway alright that's it
for this week but before you go why not
drop down in the comments and let us
know what you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]